SPEAKER: The following content
is provided under a Creative
Commons License.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: This Wednesday
will be the first
celebration of learning.
Test 1 on Wednesday, October 7,
you will write during the
normal class time.
So you'll have 50 minutes.
And we want to have a little
bit of comfort here, so you
won't be sitting
cheek to jowl.
So before long I'll have
the room assignment.
So some of you will
write in here.
We'll have fewer people than
seats so that there'll be
vacancies next to each person.
And then some will write in a
few of the other locations,
probably 26-100 and the gym
above the Walker Memorial.
And we'll get that out to you.
And next week on the 6th we
will have no weekly quiz,
because enough celebrating.
No point in testing you on the
6th and then on the 7th.
There will be, of course,
the mini-celebration
tomorrow, quiz 3.
And I'll be available for office
hours later today.
Oh, and the coverage, just to
remove the mystery, will be
right up to the 7th
of October.
I've been doing this for over 30
years and I've learned that
in order to inspire interest on
the part of the student it
really pays to have the coverage
of the celebration
extend up to the lecture
before the celebration.
Now obviously I'm not going to
drill deep on something I
taught you on October 5, but
it would be a good idea to
stay awake during all of the
lectures between now and then.
So last day we talked
about ionic bonding.
And ionic bonding occurs with
electrostatic attraction
between ions that have formed
through electron transfer.
And we saw the energy of the
ion pair given by this
formula, where we have
Coulomb's law
with the Born exponent.
And then this is plotted.
This is E at r equals r0, and we
learned that there were two
terms. The attractive term,
which is the Coulombic force
here shown.
And then there's a repulsive
term, which results from
electron-electron interaction
when the two lines get very,
very close together.
And this is taken
from your text.
And I think they did a very nice
job here of illustrating
as you go to high values of r
they're depicting that you
have the ions separated by
considerable distance.
And there's a certain
amount of stored
energy, but not a lot.
And then if you go much, much
closer than the hard sphere
sum of the ionic radii, I think
they're depicting here
that there's some squashing
of the electron clouds.
And you can see that the energy
has gone way, way up.
So this is an unfavorable
situation, meaning that the
energy here is greater than 0.
And there's a sweet spot here
at 236 picometers, which
represents the ideal location.
And that is the sum of the
radius of the sodium ion and
the radius of the
chloride ion.
And so you can see how
energy tracks.
And if you go far, far, far
away to the point where
they're at infinite separation,
there's no energy stored.
So everything makes sense.
And then we said, well what
happens if we keep packing
these things?
We rationalized that they would
continue to do so and
ultimately form a 3-dimensional
crystal.
And so you can see there's a
lot of similarity between
what's above and what's
down here.
This has been written
for a 1-1 system.
In other words, a cation plus
1 and an anion minus 1.
But it could be mediated
by the valences.
And what we have here is
the structure factor.
This Madelung constant tells us
how much we get decrease in
the energy of the system
by going to a
3-dimensional array.
So depending on the atomic
arrangement we'll have a
different value of Madelung
constant.
We saw that for sodium chloride
the value is 1.7476.
And different crystals have
different things.
And what determines the
crystal structure?
It's a combination of
the size of the two
ions and their valence.
So what we saw for sodium
chloride, this
is a structure type.
So obviously sodium chloride
is sodium chloride crystal
structure, but there is an
entire suite of compounds that
have radius ratios and charges
that end up with a sodium
chloride type crystal
structure.
And then towards the end we
started looking at the
Born-Haber Cycle.
And the purpose of the
Born-Haber Cycle was to give
us a sense of scale of the
various constituents in the
formation of a crystal.
And what we noted, the takeaway
message from the
Born-Haber Cycle, is that this
enthalpy of crystallization,
which is basically this
term here, is huge.
It's huge.
It was the big component of the
energy required to form
the crystal.
It's large and it is negative.
So what I want to do today
is start by talking about
shortcomings of the business
of ionic bonding.
See, how did we get
to ionic bonding?
We started with this idea
of octet stability.
Octet stability was
the driving idea
behind all of this.
Octet stability, and in the case
of ionic bonding this was
via electron transfer.
And so that got us a long way,
but it has its limitations.
So let's put up some new data.
So suppose I look at compounds
like H2, N2, O2.
Do these things form
ionic bonds?
How does octet stability
play here?
And so let's start by
looking at hydrogen.
So if we took hydrogen and
started with atomic hydrogen
and added an electron to it,
then we would form an anion
known as H minus.
And H minus looks pretty good
because it's isoelectronic
with helium.
So maybe this isn't going
to be so bad a day.
But if we're going to have
a bond then we need
to form an H plus.
So let's do that.
So that would be, then, H goes
to H plus, plus an electron.
And that's really nothing
more than a proton.
So that doesn't look
too appealing.
That's probably a high
energy state.
And besides, in the same
location at the same time--
in other words, same
temperature, same conditions--
half of the hydrogens have to
acquire electrons and half of
the hydrogens have to
lose electrons.
And that's not going
to happen.
They're either going to have a
propensity for electron gain
or a propensity for
electron loss.
So it looks like ionic bonding
is not going to help us
explain the formation
of molecules such as
H2, N2, and so on.
So who came to the rescue
in this case to get
us out of the conundrum?
G.N.
Lewis.
Lewis was actually born in
Weymouth, Massachusetts and he
finished his PhD at
Harvard in 1899.
And then, like so many Americans
of the day, went off
to Europe and he postdoc'd
in Europe for a while.
And then he came back and
got a job at MIT.
And he taught at MIT
from 1905 to 1912.
And then in 1912 he was lured
to the West Coast where they
were starting to establish the
chemistry department, the
University of California at
Berkeley, and he went out to
Berkeley and that's where he
spent the rest of his career.
And we can speculate
why he went.
Maybe he was fed up with
the weather here.
Actually, today is one of those
few days-- write it
down, because one of the few
lovely days in Massachusetts.
So G.N.
Lewis, what did he say?
He said, well I've
got an idea here.
He said, what if hydrogen
achieved shell filling not by
electron transfer but
by electron sharing.
So he posited the idea of shell
filling by electron sharing.
This is in contrast to
electron transfer.
So let's see.
Oh.
There's an image of G.N.
Lewis.
He died, actually, on the job.
He came back to his
lab one day after
lunch and hit the floor.
So he worked right
to the very end.
Here's some data taken
from a lab
notebook and memo, actually.
1902.
And what do you see here?
Well, he developed a notation
for us, and we still use this
notation to this day:
Lewis notation.
So here's lithium and he's
got one electron.
But we know lithium has
three electrons but
only one valence electron.
And then there's beryllium
and magnesium--
two electrons.
Aluminum with three.
Here's fluorine chlorine, and
when they ionize he puts the
eighth electron right here.
And look at this one
for silicon.
He's got probably some kernel
inside the atom, thus.
So he's even starting to think
about concentric shells.
This is 1902.
Remember the Bohr model
isn't until 1913.
So you can see people
struggling.
And notice that we have eight
electrons in a shell--
that's where we're getting
the octet stability--
and he's using cubes.
Now we know that the cube isn't
the shape of the shell,
but it's a pretty good device
to help you keep track of
electron number--
because there's eight
corners on a cube.
So it's another example of how
that's not what it is but it's
a really good model and it keeps
you out of trouble and
allows you to go forward.
So this is going back-- way,
way back-- for G.N.
Lewis.
Now let's use this idea
and account for the
formation of H2.
So here's hydrogen, and using
the Lewis notation we'll put a
dot here for its one electron.
And we'll bring in a second
hydrogen and we'll use a
cross, or an x, to indicate
the electron
from the second hydrogen.
And now we're going
to double count--
in other words, double
attribute.
These are shared electrons so
they count for both atoms.
Double count the shared
electrons.
And when you do so what
do you come up with?
Well, the element on the left
has two electrons and,
therefore, is isoelectronic
with helium.
OK?
Maybe it was a California
thing.
They were sharing.
And then there was
sort of another
California concept, like.
So it was like helium.
And then on this side this
is also sharing.
And it's kind of like helium.
So now we've achieved the
stability of the filled shell
by sharing the electrons.
OK.
And I think I even have
another slide of how--
this is the more modern
version of it.
Electron dot.
So the nucleus and the
inner-electrons are contained
inside the chemical symbol.
And, actually, this goes
all the way to
modern quantum mechanics.
Density functional theory does
the same thing: lumps all of
the inner-shell electrons plus
the nucleus into one piece,
and then the valence electrons
are outside.
And so starting in 1902 with
some little dots and crosses
we go all the way
to DFT today.
All right.
So let's do another one.
How about nitrogen?
Let's try nitrogen.
So when we going to nitrogen
we know the valence
electron's 2s2 2p3.
So put nitrogen here.
One, two, three, four, five.
Now these three electrons
here are
according to the Hund rule.
So it's px, py, pz, and this is
the 2s2 sitting over here.
And I'll bring in a second
nitrogen, and there's its 2s2.
2px, 2py, 2pz.
And now what do I have?
Look at the nitrogen
on the left.
Two, four, six, eight.
So the nitrogen on the left
feels as though it has access
to eight electrons.
The nitrogen on the right--
two, four, six, eight-- it
feels as though it has access
to eight electrons.
So both nitrogens are
isoelectronic with neon if we
push on this concept of
electron sharing.
Now there's a second
thing I want to do.
It's to draw attention to
two types of orbitals.
So these three orbitals in the
center consist of electrons
that are shared.
So these are going to be called
bonding orbitals.
And "bonding" and "blue" both
begin with a "b", so I'm going
to denote the bonding orbitals,
or bonding domains,
as distinct from the nonbonding
domains in red.
Red are nonbonding domains.
Always two electrons
per orbital.
They like to live in pairs.
That's the way it works.
OK?
And so each one of these
pairs is a bond.
So I can then write nitrogen
with three lines through it
indicating I have
a triple bond.
Three pairs of electrons,
three bonding
domains, triple bond.
This is all in formation
according to the concept of
electron sharing.
And Lewis coined a name for
the type of bond that is
formed in this way.
He said we get bond formation
involves cooperative use--
sharing, cooperative--
of valence electrons.
So now we can take the "co"
symbol here and the "valence"
here and come up with the term
"covalent bond." Covalent
bond, thanks to G.N.
Lewis.
So, again, to make sure we're
very clear, ionic bond results
from electron transfer, covalent
bond results from
electron sharing.
Now we can do this-- so let's go
to heteronuclear molecules.
These are homonuclear.
So let's go to heteronuclear
molecules.
And so let's see.
I've got some rules
up here, I think.
Yeah.
Drawing Lewis structures.
So let's go to a heteronuclear
molecule.
And I'm going to choose as an
example sulfuryl chloride.
And I don't expect you
to be able to name
these things on site.
I will always give
you the name.
I'll say sulfuryl chloride,
parenthesis, SO2Cl2, blah,
blah, blah.
OK?
So sulfuryl chloride.
I want to put up the Lewis
structure of sulfuryl chloride.
So center the element with the
lowest average valence
electron energy.
So it turns out that the average
valence electron
energy stack like this.
Sulfur is the lowest, then
chlorine, and then oxygen.
This is this ranking of average
valence electron energies.
And you'd be given those data.
So it says put sulfur
in the center.
So I'll put sulfur
And then what does it say?
We're going to count all
the valence electrons.
So sulfur over here
is 3s2 3p4.
So that gives me six
valence electrons.
And there's two oxygens.
And oxygen lies above sulfur,
so that's 2s2 2p4.
So that's 2 times 6.
So that's 12.
All right?
Let's put the 6 over here.
And then there's chlorines
in this compound,
so that's 3s2 3p5.
So that's 5 plus 2 is
7, 2 times 7 is 14.
And we add this whole
thing up, we get
there's 32 valence electrons.
And draw a single bond from each
surrounding atom to the
central atom.
All right.
Again, this is a model.
I'm not saying that this is the
shape of the molecule, but
it's a way to count.
All I'm doing is trying
to keep track of
bonds and paired electrons.
So I can put chlorine
on either side.
And I'll put an oxygen below
and an oxygen above.
All right.
So that's already two,
four, six, eight.
So I'm losing eight.
So 32 minus 8 is 24.
And so with the 24 that means
I've got 12 pairs of
electrons to place.
So let's start putting the
Lewis structures up.
So chlorine consists
of one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven.
And I'll do the same thing
on the other side.
Two, four, six, seven.
And oxygen has six, so that's
two, four, six.
And then the lower
one, same thing.
Two, four, six.
And sulfur has six.
I'm going to use
x's for sulfur.
So I'll put one x with
the chlorine,
another x with the chlorine.
Two with the oxygen, two
with the oxygen.
And so now we're in pretty
good shape, right?
We can identify bonding and
nonbonding domains.
Here's the bonding.
One, two, three, four.
And then the nonbonding.
Looks like there's 12.
And sure enough, 1, 2, 3, 4,
5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12.
The 12 nonbonding domains.
4 bonds.
And we have the Lewis
structure for
this particular compound.
And one last little piece
worth pointing out.
Notice that in the bonds to
the chlorine you have two
electrons, as you need.
One electron comes from the
chlorine and one electron
comes from sulfur.
But in the bonds between the
sulfur and the oxygen the
sulfur's so desperate to form
a bond that it actually
donates both electrons
to the bond.
And oxygen's happy because it's
isoelectronic with neon,
and sulfur's happy because it's
going to be isoelectronic
with argon.
But, you know, it has to
go to some lengths.
So this is called a dative bond,
when both electrons come
from the one element.
OK.
Well, this is great.
I'm going to do one more.
How about methane?
CH4.
So I'm going to start
with carbon.
Carbon's going to go
with this on there.
And a carbon is 2s2 2p2.
And so I'm going to use
the box notation now.
See, this is the Lewis
structure, this is chemical
equation, now we're going
to a box structure.
We can move fluidly from
one model to another.
We had cubes up there.
It's all good.
So this is 2s.
And now this is 2px,
2py, and 2pz.
Now according to this,
2s2, that gives
me an electron pair.
And now I've got 2p2, which
according to the Hund rule
goes in like this.
Well I've got a problem here.
How many unpaired electrons?
Two.
Now what's my maximum number
of bonds I can form by
electron sharing?
It's two according to this.
So the best I can do, best
possible here, is CH2.
And that's no good.
We know from mass measurements
it's CH4.
The stoichiometry's CH4.
And besides, what are these
orbitals going to look like?
These are the p orbitals, so
they're dumbbell-shaped and
they're orthogonal, right?
They're 90 degrees, which means
if I formed this thing--
which is called methylene--
if I form methylene I'd end up
with CH2 looking like this,
which has a dipole moment.
And we know from spectral
measurements and electrical
properties measurements that
this thing is symmetric.
So this thing--
electron sharing
isn't working.
It's not working.
So we need another patch here,
and that patch comes from none
other than Linus Pauling.
Another American.
You see, it's American science
today and it's in the 20s.
That's why we have Gershwin
playing at the beginning.
Celebration of American
science.
So Pauling was born in
Portland, Oregon.
He was the son of a pharmacist.
And he went to
Caltech, got his PhD in 1925.
So the Rhapsody in Blue came out
in 1924 when he was just
hunkering down to his thesis.
Probably listened to it, got
some pleasure out of it, as
most people did.
So then he finishes, 1925, at
Caltech in Pasadena and he
goes to Europe.
Now he chose wisely.
He chose four postdoctoral
positions.
These are people he
postdoc'd with.
First with Sommerfeld, then
with Bohr, then with
Schrodinger, and then
finally with Bragg.
You'll learn about Bragg.
Bragg got the Nobel Prize
for X-ray diffraction.
So that's not a bad
preparatory start.
So he comes back and
teaches at Caltech.
In fact, I have a picture
of Linus Pauling.
There he is.
That's a middle-aged Linus
Pauling, probably around the
time he got the first
of two Nobel Prizes.
So what did Pauling do?
Pauling said, why don't
we mix the orbitals?
They're all in the shell n
equals 2, and what we're
trying to do is to fill
the n equals 2 shell.
So how about mix?
Let's mix 2s and 2p states
in order to maximize
the number of bonds.
Remember, when you form a
bond you decrease the
energy of the system.
Four bonds is a greater
decrease in
energy than two bonds.
So the system, if it could--
and they're all within
the same shell.
You notice he didn't say, gee,
if mixing 2s with 2p is good
let's go get some 1s.
Well 1s is down in n equals
1, and there's
no way you can mix.
They had to be in
the same shell.
Mix states in order to
maximize number of
bonds that can form.
It's all about maximize
the number of
bonds that can be formed.
And this, of course, is
by electron sharing.
We're talking about covalent
bonds here.
OK?
And he termed these mixed
orbitals "hybrids." Termed the
mixed orbitals as "hybrid
orbitals." They're
cross-breed--
part s, part p.
So now let's look at the
energy level diagram--
or the box notation.
Forgive me.
So I'm going to mix s and p.
So I've got a single s and I've
got three p's, so this is
called sp3.
Each one of these is a mixed
sp3 hybrid orbital.
And I've got four of them.
And how many electrons
do I have?
Four.
So now I use the Hund rule
and in go the electrons.
One, two, three, four.
And now I have the ability
to form four bonds.
But it gets better.
Here's the next thing.
These are degenerate.
They're all in the same state.
That's why we're using
the Hund rule.
And so degeneracy in energy
implies degeneracy in spatial
orientation.
So what does that mean?
It means that if these are four
bonds equivalent, then
the way those bonds will arrange
themselves in space is
to be equivalent.
So if I've got a central carbon
here and I'm going to
put four sticks from the central
carbon so as to make
the four sticks symmetrically
disposed in space, that
dictates the architecture
of the molecule.
And how do I put four sticks
off of a central point
symmetrically disposed
in space?
One, two, three, and four.
This is meant to be the corners
of a tetrahedron.
Each one of these is
109 degrees apart.
And this describes
a tetrahedron.
So now I've got carbon in the
center, and now I've got the
hydrogens at the four corners
of a tetrahedron.
There is the structure
of methane.
And each of the hydrogens has
a shared electron with the
carbon, making it isoelectronic
with helium.
And the carbon has four of its
own electrons, four shared
with the four hydrogens
to make it
isoelectronic with neon.
So everybody's happy.
Shell filling, and
it's all good.
So now it's symmetric and it
has no net dipole moment.
Everything squares
with the data.
Well, good for Pauling.
But he went further.
He went much further.
What Pauling wanted to do was
to make it quantitative.
And so he wanted to have
something analogous in
covalent bonding to what we
have in ionic bonding.
So what Leslie is now rubbing
off the board there is--
no, keep going.
It's good.
It's OK.
This is a rule of academics:
You always erase that which
you will refer back to.
We need more boards in here.
How many boards do I
fill in a period?
9, 18?
Maybe what?
We need about 24 boards.
That's a good lecture.
All right.
So here's what Pauling
was thinking about.
He was thinking about the
analogy, for example, if I
want to get the energy of
magnesium oxide I can use the
formula that Leslie has
just erased, and
it looks like this.
So if all I need to know is the
radius of the anion, the
radius of the cation, it's
charge, and the Madelung
constant and then I just
plug in, I get the
crystallization energy.
But then suppose instead of
magnesium oxide I want to go
to magnesium chloride.
I can use the same formula
only I need
the Madelung constant.
This is the Madelung constant
for magnesium oxide.
If I have the Madelung
constant--
forgive me, script M--
for magnesium chloride, and
I know the ionic radius of
magnesium cation and chloride
anion, away I go again.
I need this.
I need, of course, the
Born exponent.
This Born exponent
and away we go.
The same formula applies.
So I can build with a library
of basic physical data.
So what did Pauling do?
Pauling said, what if we
can do the same thing
for covalent bonds?
Is there some kind
of an analogy?
So he said, let's take a
look at an arbitrary
heteronuclear compound.
So I'm going to do this with
HF, hydrogen fluoride.
So, first of all, let's build a
hydrogen fluoride molecule.
H with its one electron, and
fluorine with its seven.
So now hydrogen sharing an
electron with fluorine is
isoelectronic with helium.
It's happy.
And fluorine sharing the
electron hydrogen is
isoelectronic with neon.
It's happy.
So again we see shell filling
by electron sharing.
So what Pauling wanted to ask
is, can I get a measure of the
HF bond energy knowing
only the bond
energies of H-H and F-F?
So then if I knew all the
homonuclear bond energies and
then I mixed these to make
heteronuclear bonds, is there
a path from homonuclear
bond energy to
heteronuclear bond energy?
So let's look and see what
the numbers are.
So hydrogen.
The hydrogen bond's
fairly strong.
It's 435 kilojoules per mole.
That's mole of bonds.
435.
Fluorine-flourine is 160.
And so what do you think
the value of the
H-F bond should be?
Well when I first look at this
I say, well it's part H and
it's part F, so it's somewhere
between 435 and 160.
I don't know if it's the
arithmetic mean--
you know, add these two and
divide by two-- or maybe it's
the geometric mean--
multiply them together and
take the square root--
but it's got to be somewhere
in between.
What do the data show?
The number's 569, which
is greater than 435.
So I take a bond of 435 and
a bond of 160, I put them
together I get 569.
That's very, very strange.
But Pauling was smart.
Pauling said, I have
an explanation.
He says, suppose when these
electrons are shared in
between the two atoms, suppose
they're not shared equally.
Suppose there is a displacement
of the electrons.
So instead of putting them
dead center, as I've been
doing up until now, suppose
the electrons are actually
drawn closer to the fluorine.
So we still have octet
stability, or in this case
duet stability, but
the sharing of the
electrons is not equal.
So this is charge
displacement.
And what does charge
displacement constitute?
Well, charge displacement
means stored energy.
And Pauling quantified
that stored energy.
And so what he did is he said
that you increase the bond
strength by thinking of it
as a two-step reaction.
So in the heteronuclear bond
that is a bond between two
different atoms. So in a
heteronuclear bond we form by
what-- and this is my coinage,
you don't see this
anywhere in the book--
two-step, share and then pull.
So share is, as the name
implies, we share electrons to
achieve octet stability.
But then because we have unequal
atoms we pull towards
one of the atoms. And which
one do we pull towards?
Well, we pull towards the one
that's got a greater appetite
for electrons.
And we've already gone
through this concept.
Which atoms on the periodic
table have the highest
appetite for electrons?
The nonmetals.
The weakest appetite
is the metals.
The metals are good donors, the
nonmetals are good acceptors.
And fluorine's up in the top
right corner, so fluorine has
a very, very high appetite
for electrons.
And, indeed, in this bond
the electrons are
pulled to the right.
And why Pauling got the Nobel
Prize and Lewis didn't-- it's
my theory-- is that Pauling
was quantitative.
So he came up with a
quantitative measure.
He devised a quantitative
measure for the degree of
unequal sharing, thereby
allowing us to make these
calculations with
some accuracy.
And he called that quantity
electronegativity, and it's
denoted by the Greek
symbol chi.
OK?
And he devised a whole scale.
How did he get the scale?
He looked at bond energies for
all sorts of pairs of elements
across the periodic table and
went through an exercise with
pencil and paper that today we
would call multivariable
regression analysis.
And came with a set of--
[SLIDE APPEARING]
PROFESSOR: Oh, I'll
come back to this.
This is the structure
of methane.
This is the s and p.
Oh, let's take a break.
You can stack.
All right.
So this is what methane
looks like.
There's the s, there's the p.
And the sp hybrid
looks like this.
It's sort of an asymmetric
dumbbell.
And these four things
stick out.
And then you bond the hydrogens
and there's the methane.
OK.
So here's what the
electronegativity scale looks like.
It looks a lot like the
scale for average
valence electron energies.
The nonmetals have the highest
appetite for electrons period,
which means in a bond they're
going to hog the electrons.
And the nonmetals have the
weakest appetite, and so
they're going to end up having
the electrons in a covalent
bond pulled away from them.
So nonmetals have high
electronegativity, metals have
low electronegativity.
And now here's taken
from the text.
And you see that the
electronegativity is periodic.
If you go across a period the
metal has the lowest value and
the nonmetal has the highest.
And there's fluorine, number
nine, at a value of about 4.
It's got the most intense
appetite for electrons.
And then you jump down here to
sodium, et cetera, et cetera.
Here we are going across the
lanthanides and whatnot.
And this is taken
from your text.
There's fluorine, 3.984.
That's the thing.
And down here we have very low
values of electronegativity.
So with electronegativity
we are now able to make
calculations.
And this is the Pauling formula
for calculating the
bond energy in a heteronuclear
bond starting from homonuclear
bond energy.
So let's continue with the HF.
So if I want to get the
bond energy of HF
I'm going to take--
and this is the Pauling
formula--
the geometric mean.
So I take the bond energy of
hydrogen-hydrogen times the
bond energy of
fluorine-fluorine, and square root.
So that's the geometric
mean of the two.
And then comes the Pauling
piece that gets
him the Nobel Prize.
You take the difference in the
electronegativity between the
two elements squared, and then
the factor 96.3 gives us the
unit consistency with
kilojoules per mole.
So the greater the difference
in electronegativity the
greater the contribution here in
terms of the deviation from
just the geometric mean of the
two homonuclear bond energies.
Or put another way, if you have
a homonuclear atom such
as H2, if it's chi H minus chi
H is 0, so this second
term goes to 0.
And obviously when fluorine is
one of the members you're
going to get a very, very
high number, because
this has the most--
and it doesn't matter which
order you put them in because
you're taking the square,
so it's always
going to come out positive.
And I want you to appreciate the
sense of scale here, so if
we go in here we'll multiply.
This is going to be
435 times 160.
And I'm going to take the
square root of this.
And then this is 96.3.
And you look on your
periodic table
this is 2.2 for hydrogen.
Fluorine is 3.98.
And I know there are different
tables of electronegativity.
I don't care.
Just whatever you've got
on your periodic table.
The one in the book is a little
bit different but it
all comes out in the wash.
So you multiply all this out,
and we find that the first
term is 264 kilojoules
per mole and the
second term is 344.
So this second term is even
greater than the first term.
So the amount of energy in that
electron displacement is
substantial.
And if you sum the two
of these you get 608.
Now you might say, well
wait a minute.
The real number is 569.
But 608 takes you in the right
direction and accounts for the
contribution of electron
displacement.
264 is just plain wrong.
So this was an important
start for Pauling.
And he has labels on these
two contributions.
This first term, which is just
the combination of the
homonuclear bond energies, is
called purely covalent.
It's the purely covalent
contribution.
And it's what I've been
referring to as the sharing.
This is what you get
from sharing.
OK?
And then this second term here
with the difference in
electronegativity is what you
get from what I've been
calling the pull on
the electron pair.
And Pauling called this the
partial ionic character.
He's not saying that there's
electron transfer, but it's a
move in that direction.
Partial electronic character.
So what I've done here is I've
decided I'll make a sort of a
panorama of what we've
seen up until now.
And so I'm going to make
something called the electron
sharing meter.
All right.
So if I look at a homonuclear
system like hydrogen.
So my meter reads neutral.
So the arrow's at 12 o'clock.
The electrons are
shared equally.
And then if I go to
HF what do I have?
Well, I know that the fluorine
is pulling the electrons.
And so we can designate that by
writing delta minus, delta
plus. delta the physicists
use.
The lowercase Greek delta
means little bit of.
All right?
So delta minus means it's
a little bit negative.
And we've got charge neutrality,
so if the fluorine
end is a little bit negative
then the hydrogen end has to
be a little bit positive, which
means this thing has a
net dipole moment.
It's a dipole.
And the arrow points to
the negative end.
One way to think about it is I
put a little slash there and
that starts to look a little
bit like a plus sign.
You can come up with your
own way to remember it.
So it's got a little bit
of a dipole moment.
And people depict dipoles
usually as ovals, and they'll
put a minus end and
a plus end.
So it's net neutral but the
charge is not uniformly
distributed.
OK?
So our sharing meter in this
case is going to show
something to the right.
We've got electrons that are
unequally shared, and that
moves over to the right.
And, you know, the dipoles have
interesting properties.
Oh, there's a plot of
electronegativity
3-bar in the bar plot.
And actually this is
an interesting one.
Just parenthetically, you
see hydrogen here?
Hydrogen's weird.
They put it in the periodic
table above lithium but it's
not an alkaline metal.
And you can see it just
doesn't belong there.
And there's a lot of
conversation about putting it
maybe somewhere centered above
the p block elements, because
it certainly doesn't belong
next to helium.
But it probably doesn't belong
above lithium either.
Anyway, I thought that
was very interesting.
I can tell from the
response of the
class, why does he care?
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: All right.
Now this is really--
I'm going to use an
adverb here--
this is really important.
All right?
So here's HCl, is a cousin of
HF, and you see in the upper
frame it's just a bunch of HCl
molecules just bopping around
any which way.
So there's the delta plus
and the delta minus.
Now if you take these dipoles
and you put them in an
electric field they will align
themselves, and the positive
ends will face the negative
plate and the negative ends
will face the positive plate.
And there's energy stored when
the random orientation goes
into an ordered orientation.
This is the principle
behind a capacitor.
A capacitor is nothing
more than a whole
bunch of aligned dipoles.
So if you want to invent a
supercapacitor that we can use
on a car to extend the range
of the automobile so we can
reduce our dependence on
imported petroleum, you're
going to look for molecules
that have a
honking big dipole moment.
That way you get more energy
per unit electric field.
So, again, a simple idea that
tells me how to go and invent.
I can go back to my office and
go and invent something right
now just based on
this lecture 9.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: See, you
go and invent.
You start the company,
you make the billion.
Remember good old Professor
Sadoway at MIT, and
established the fellowship
for students, and so.
All right.
But you have to know what
a dipole moment is.
Got to know what a
dipole moment is.
OK.
So there's the dipole moment.
And then lastly I'm going
to put sodium chloride.
So what's sodium chloride
look like?
Well it's Na plus
and Cl minus.
So the electron has transferred
completely.
So this isn't even
sharing at all.
So this is really
bury the needle.
This is not sharing.
In this instance the sodium
doesn't even get visitation
rights to the electron.
The electron's gone.
Whereas here hydrogen gets to
see the electron on Saturdays
kind of thing.
Depends what kind of lawyer
fluorine had.
That's what it all
boils down to.
All right.
This is the same thing that
I just showed you.
But you see, the textbook
gives you, as the name
implies, dense text.
I gave you the sharing meter.
The sharing meter is far
more expositive.
All right.
And then, finally, the percent
ionic character is given by
this formula here.
So this is 1 minus
the exponential.
So the exp term, this
exponential of-- what is it--
minus 1/4 times the
difference in
electronegativities squared.
This notation means e base
natural logarithms, minus 1/4,
blah, blah, blah.
That's what this thing is.
So if you plug in, multiply by
100% you get something that
goes from 0 to 100.
So obviously when delta
chi is 0 you get 0%.
e to the 0 is 1, 1 minus
1 is 0, and so you
have no ionic character.
And so if you plug in
the numbers for HF--
so you're going to take this
difference here, square it--
it ends up giving you 1.8, which
gives you a value of
about 56% ionic character.
So it's as though the electron
is sort of half transferred.
But you might also look at
it from this perspective.
If you take 344--
because this is the partial
ionic character, which is the
energy of electron displacement
over the total
energy in the calculation--
that turns out to be 57%.
So this stuff makes sense.
There's a sensible metric
here at work.
And so this is what Linus
Pauling got his Nobel Prize
for, and it's the description
of polar covalency.
And polar covalency is operative
when you have
heteronuclear bonds, because
the two different elements
don't share the electron
equally.
And the Pauling formula allows
you to calculate that.
And his formative book was
written in 1937, called The
Nature of the Chemical Bond.
OK.
So turning to the last five
minutes, I want to bring to
your attention some covalent
molecules.
Today we're going to
talk about Freon.
Freon was an invention, it was
a designer chemical, invented
by Thomas Midgley.
This is me.
I named him "sp3." That's
his nickname.
Thomas sp3, for the hybridized
orbital.
So he was working at the
Dayton engineering
laboratories in Dayton, which
was owned by General Motors,
and he was working in the 20s
at a time when there were no
refrigerators in American
kitchens.
The only refrigerants that were
used were either toxic or
flammable, things like ammonia,
methyl chloride,
sulfur dioxide.
And you read about horrible
accidents.
People making ice cream at some
plant and the compressor
blows up and two or three
people are killed.
So it was deemed unsafe in
the American kitchen.
In the 20s Midgley discovered
this molecule, which looks
just like methane only we've
replace the hydrogens with two
chlorines and two fluorines.
So this is called
dichlorodifluoromethane and
it's a chlorofluorocarbon,
a CFC.
And this was fantastic stuff.
It it was colorless, odorless,
tasteless, non-toxic.
It was not just used as a
refrigerant, it was used in
propellant.
When I was your age all
of the sprays--
whether it was hair spray,
shaving cream, any aerosol--
was propelled by Freon-12.
It was fantastic stuff.
Well, it turns out that in
the upper atmosphere--
you know, you go pss pss pss.
You got people all over the
world doing this, eventually
this stuff starts
floating away.
And what turns out in the upper
atmosphere where we
don't have shielding
from ultraviolet--
you know how to do this
calculation, because you can
look up the energy.
And, in fact, it's part of your
homework, where you look
at the energy differences and
the electronegativity
differences, you can compute the
wavelength of light that's
capable of breaking the
carbon-chlorine bond.
And it turns out to be
in the ultraviolet.
Once the chlorine is broken you
have a chlorine radical,
and that chlorine radical goes
over here and attacks ozone.
[CELL PHONE RINGING]
PROFESSOR: Cell phone--
out.
Just get up and leave
out of courtesy.
[CELL PHONE STILL RINGING]
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: Hello?
The first year I was teaching
3.091 there was a Nobel Prize
awarded to Mario Molina, who was
a faculty member here in
Earth and Planetary Sciences who
had worked years earlier
at University of California,
Irvine, and had speculated on
the mechanism by which ozone
depletion occurs and linked it
to rising levels of CFCs.
Initially--
that's why it says
a vindication--
people pooh poohed it,
said it was crazy.
There wasn't enough of this pss
pss to cause any trouble.
But then later with the NASA
program they started taking a
lot of images and they could
track ozone levels in the
atmosphere and start seeing
that not only was ozone
changing but there were actually
pockets where ozone
was being depleted at an
accelerating rate-- because
obviously the atmosphere isn't
constant composition and
constant temperature.
Duh.
So anyways, yeah.
There he is.
And this was the paper that was
published in 1974 in Nature.
And this was done before
computers.
The PC wasn't invented
and commercialized
until the early 80s.
So this was typeset, and the
person who typeset it
obviously didn't take 3.091
because instead of "atom"
hyphen "catalysed" we have
"atomc-atalysed." But even
ignoring the spelling error in
a Nobel Prize winning paper--
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: --the Nobel committee
overlooked this.
Yeah.
So there it is.
And then they went to
HFCs and so on.
There's a lot of activity
in this.
And what happened is when we
changed from CFCs to HFCs we
had to change the design
of the compressors.
And what happened was
everything got
much, much more efficient.
So this was an example of
necessity for a change that
was driven by concern
for the environment.
Instead of putting people out
of work and killing an
industry, gave us much more
efficient refrigeration.
And the last thing I'll
show you is this
to draw your attention.
This was in your textbook.
This is the cap at the top of
the Washington Monument.
The Washington Monument was
built to celebrate the
American centennial, 1876.
They finished it in 1884.
And this is 100 ounces of
aluminum, because aluminum was
a precious metal.
It was priced higher
than silver.
1884.
Two years later Charles Martin
Hall and Paul Heroult invent
an electrochemical process
that drives the price of
aluminum down to the point
that we make beer cans--
I mean soda cans--
out of it today.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: And a good example of
how chemical innovation can
lead to superior products.
I'll see you on Wednesday.